[موسيقى]
مساء الخير مشروع الحزام والطريق والمشروع
الجديد المنافس له الممر الاقتصادي هو
موضوع حلقتنا اليوم
يصادف هذه الايام الذكرى العاشره لانطلاق
مبادره الحزام والطريق التي اعلن عنها
الرئيس الصيني في سبتمبر 2013
المشروع الذي يعد الاكبر في التاريخ ما
زال يطرح في ذكراه العاشره مجموعه من
الاسئله اولها ماذا تريد الصين من هذا
المشروع العملاق ماذا استفادت منه وماذا
استفادت الدول المشاركه فيه هل هذا
المشروع فعلا نقطه ارتكاز لنظام عالمي
جديد تقوده الصين ام على العكس هو مشروع
طموح اكثر مما ينبغي وسيغرق الصين
وشركائها في ديون تقضي على امال هذه الدول
في التنميه وتقضي على امال الصين في
الصداره والصعود وما الفرق بين الحزام
والطريق والمشروع الذي اطلق مؤخرا
لمنافسته وهو مشروع الممر الاقتصادي الذي
ضربه الهند والخليج باوروبا عبر اسرائيل
الاجابه على هذه الاسئله تقتضي ان نعرف
بدايه ما هو طريق الحزام والطريق وماذا
حقق حتى الان وما التحديات التي تواجهه
البدايه كانت في صباح 8 سبتمبر 2013 في
هذا اليوم اعلن الرئيس شيلي اول مره عن
مبادره غامضه لاحياء طريق الحرير البري
خلال زياره الله لدوله كازاخستان ثم اعلن
عن طريق حرير بحري في الشهر التالي في
اندونيسيا وتحديدا في ثلاثه اكتوبر 2013
المبادره بشقيها عرفت لاحقا باسم مبادره
الحزام والطريق يشير الحزام لشبكه طرق
بريه والطريق يشير لشبكه طرق بحريه
وكلاهما يربط الصين بالعالم تماما كما فعل
طريق الحرير التاريخي وما هو طريق الحرير
التاريخي عباره عن شبكه طرق وليس طريقا
واحدا كما يوحي
بدا انشاء هذه الطرق اباطره الصين قبل
الميلاد من حوالي 2100 سنه هذه الطرق ربطت
الصين بمراكز التجاره في العالم وقتها
وتحديدا اوروبا عبر دول اسيا الوسطى
وجنوبها جنوبها اللي هي ايه اللي هي الهند
وباكستان بالاضافه الى دول الشرق الاوسط
هذه الشبكه سميت بطريق الحرير لان الحرير
كان اشهر صادرات الصين لهذه الدول وظل
طريق الحرير مزدهرا حتى تراجعت اهميته
لعده اسباب منها الاكتشافات الجغرافيه
البحريه بدايه من اواخر القرن ال 15
ببساطه ادى امكانيه نقل الكثير من البضائع
بشكل اسرع وتكلفه اقل بحريا لتراجع اهميه
هذه الشبكه من الطرق البريه وبعيدا عن
المسميات مشروع الحزام والطريق هو فعلا
احياء لطريق الحريق ولكن بمعايير القرن ال
21 طريق الحرير كان عباره عن طرق بريه
بسيطه بتعبر
من خلالها الخيول والجمال اما طريق الحرير
او طريق الحزام والطريق فهو شبكه واسعه من
الطرق البريه السريعه والمعابر الحدوديه
والسكك الحديديه والموانئ البحريه والجويه
وخطوط انابيب الطاقه الطريق بدا في
اتجاهين اساسيين غربا عبر اسيا الوسطى
وجنوبا عبر باكستان والهند الاول يصل
لاوروبا والثاني يربط الصين بالشرق الاوسط
وافريقيا لاحقا تم التوسع في المشروع على
كل المستويات جغرافيا مثلا امتد المشروع
الذي كان يركز على اسيا وافريقيا واوروبا
الى امريكا اللاتينيه البرازيل والارجنتين
وغيرهما
ركز كثيرا المشروع لاحقا على الموانئ
البحريه حول العالم في البدايه كانت جميع
المشاريع في بنيه تحتيه تقليديه موانئ
مطارات سكك حديديه لكن منذ الاعلان عن
طريق الحرير الرقمي في 2015
مشروعات اخرى في كابلات الالياف الضوئيه
ومحطات طاقه شمسيه وشبكات محمول من الجيل
الخامس الى اخره الصين بتخطط لبناء خمسين
منطقه اقتصاديه خاصه على الاقل على طول
هذه الطرق انضم حتى هذه اللحظه للمبادره
نحو 150 دوله حتى الان منهم 18 دوله في
منطقه الشرق الاوسط وشمال افريقيا الدول
ال 150 بتمثل ما يقرب من 75% من سكان
الارض واكثر من نصف الناتج المحلي
الاجمالي للعالم اللي هو حوالي 100
تريليون دولار ووفقا لوزير الخارجيه
الصيني فان حجم الاستثمارات في هذه
المبادره حتى مارس الماضي 2023 بلغت
تريليون دولار يعني حوالي الف مليار دولار
تم استثمارها في اطلاق اكثر من 3000 مشروع
هذه المشروعات وفقا للصينيين خلقت نحو 420
الف فرصه عمل
اربعين مليون انسان من الفقر ما الذي تامل
الصين في تحقيقه من هذا المشروع العملاق
الهدف المعلن التعاون الاقتصادي بطريقه
يعني الصين بتقول للدول المشاركه معها سوف
ابني عندكم مشروعات تفيدكم وتدر دخلا عليا
دون وجود اي مارب سياسيه او محاوله بناء
تحالفات تستهدف الغرب الرئيس شيري قال ذلك
عده مرات وباكثر من صيغه مثلا قال مبادره
الحزام والطريق مبادره للتعاون الاقتصادي
وليس التحالفات الجيو سياسيه او العسكريه
قال الصين لا تلعب لعبه المحصله الصفريه
يعني اربح انا وتخسر انت قال لن نلجا الى
مناورات جيو سياسيه عفا عليها الزمن اثناء
تاسيسنا لمشروع الحزام والطريق المشروع
فعلا له اهداف اقتصاديه واضحه للصين وفي
حال نجاحه فوائده واضحه للصينيين ويمكن في
نقطتين واحد استيعاب الطاقه الانتاجيه
للشركات الصينيه العملاقه خصوصا في مجال
البنيه التحتيه بعد ان تشبع السوق الصيني
تقريبا ولم يعد كافيا لابقاء هذه الشركات
رابحه في طاقه انتاجيه ضخمه في الصين لا
يمكن ابدا ان تظل هذه الطاقه الانتاجيه
موجوده في الصين وحدها الى الابد لابد ان
تخرج الى دول العالم المختلفه حتى تعمل
هذه الشركات وتربح وتظل الصين اقتصادا
منتعشا ومشروع الحزام والطريق يحقق هذا
الهدف اثنين تحقيق الاستقرار الداخلي ليه
لانه التنميه في الصين حتى سنوات قليله
مضت كانت بتتركز في الاقاليم الشرقيه او
في الجزء الشرقي من الصين لكن الاقاليم
الغربيه تحديدا وبعض الاقاليم الجنوبيه
اهملت الى حد كبير بتامل الصين انه هذه
الاقاليم تنتعش وتنمو بوتيره اسرع من خلال
مشروع الالتزام الطريق الذي سوف يربطها
بدول الجوار والامثله على ذلك كثيره منها
مثلا مقاطعه الغربيه اللي هي مشهوره في
العالم لانها يعني بتشهد اضطرابات سياسيه
وبتشهد متاعب كثيره لمسلمي الاجور وبتامل
القياده الصينيه انه اذا انتعش الاقتصاد
هناك تقل حده الاضطرابات السياسيه هناك
وتقل الرغبه لدى بعض مسلم للاجور في
الانفصال او في تحدي السلطه الصينيه هناك
لكن هذا الكلام بطبيعه الحال لم يقنع احدا
خصوصا في الغرب هم غير مقتنعين ان الهدف
اقتصادي فقط هم مقتنعون ان هناك اهداف
اخرى وحتى الهدف الاقتصادي لن يتم بطريقه
ابلع واستحوذ وسيطر على الدول الفقيره
اجمالا الولايات المتحده وكثير من حلفائها
يرون ثلاثه اهداف رئيسيه للصين من هذا
المشروع
في الاول هو رغبه الصين في الاستحواذ على
مقدرات الدول الفقيره هم يعتقدون ان هذا
المشروع ليس الا فخا او مصاد الديون للدول
الناشئه ما الذي يعنيه ذلك الغرب بيتهم
الصين بانها بتستخدم الحزام والطريق
كوسيله لابتلاع الدول الصغيره من خلال
تمويل مشاريع بنيه تحتيه هامه واستراتيجيه
بقروض تعلم الصين سلفا ان هذه الدول لن
تستطيع سددها وعندما تعجز هذه الدول عن
السداد بتصبح المنشات التي بنيت بالقروض
الصينيه موانئ مطارات مدن صناعيه ملكا
للصينيين وربما تصبح الدوله باكملها تحت
الوصايه الصينيه واشنطن وحلفائها عاده ما
بيشير الى مثاله واحد رئيسي لاثبات وجهه
نظرهم وهو ميناء هامبونتاتا في سريلانكا
موالت الصين هذا الميناء الاستراتيجي
المهم على المحيط الهندي لم تتمكن الحكومه
السريلانكيه التي افلست مؤخرا من السداد
بدايه من 2017 واضطرت لتسليم الميناء
المهمه للصينيين من خلال توقيع عقد ايجار
مدته 99 عاما يعني الصين وضعت يدها على
الميناء لمده 100 سنه قادمه
الولايات المتحده بتصر على ان ما حدث في
ميناء هامبونتاتا ليس حاله استثنائيه
ولكنه نموذج تسعى الصين الاتباعه مع كل
الدول التي اقترضت منها من خلال مشروع
الحزام والطريق وانه الصين في نهايه
المطاف سوف تستحوذ على كل الاصول او يعني
المشروعات الحيويه الهامه في كل هذه الدول
التي اقترضت منها
الصين بتنفي هذه التهمه ليلا ونهارا وبعض
الخبراء يعني او المتابعين الموضوعيين في
الغرب بيشككوا في ان هذا التوجه عام للصين
وبيقولوا لا يوجد دليل على ان الصين تتعمد
اعطاء الدول قرودا هي تعلم سلفا انها سوف
تعجز عن سدادها واستحواذ الصين على اصل او
اصلان في اي دوله اخرى لا يعني ان هذا
اتجاه عام لا يثبت هذه النظريه الامريكيه
على العموم الهدف الثاني من وجهه النظر
الغرب من مشروع الحزام والطريق هو انه هذا
المشروع قادر على تامين امدادات الطاقه من
اسيا الوسطى والشرق الاوسط وافريقيا
للصين عبر طرق بعيده عن السيطره العسكريه
الامريكيه اي ايجاد حل لما يعرف في الصين
بمعدله ملقى وما هي معضله ملقى ببساطه
ايجاد طرق لوصول الطاقه الصين بعيدا عن
مديك ملقا الشهير اقتصاد الصين بيعتمد
بنسبه كبيره على واردات الطاقه التي تاتيه
من الخارج الصين بتوفر من احتياجاتها في
الطاقه 30% فقط
وبتستورد حوالي سبعين في الميه من
احتياجاتها من الطاقه من الخارج وتحديدا
من الشرق الاوسط
وبعض دول افريقيا مثل انجولا معظم هذه
الواردات بتمر 80% منها تقريبا بيمر عشان
يصل الى الصين عبر مدينه ملقى واين يقع
مديك ملقا بيقع ضمن المياه الاقليميه
لثلاثه دول هي اندونيسيا وماليزيا
وسنغافوره في حاله نشوب اي صراع بتخشى
الصين ان تقنع او تجبر امريكا الدول
الثلاث او احداها باغلاق المضيق ما يحرم
الصين من واردات الطاقه وبالتالي يشعر
الاقتصادها مبادره الحزام والطريق بتحل
هذه المشكله بطريقتين الاولى توفير ممرات
بريه لوصول واردات الطاقه للصين بشكل امن
وبعيد عن الاساطيل الامريكيه يمكن للصين
مثلا ان تحصل على بترولها وغازها من ايران
ومن دول اسيا الوسطى بريا بعيدا عن
الممرات البحريه التي تسيطر عليها
الولايات المتحده
الثانيه هي تامين وارداتها البحريه من
خلال الانتشار العسكري الذي تعتقد امريكا
ان الصين سوف تحققه في النهايه باستحواذه
على موانئ استراتيجيه حول العالم من خلال
طريقه فخ الديون اللي انا اشرت اليها في
النقطه الاولى ثالثا وهو الهدف النهائي من
مشروع الحزام والطريق كما تتصوره الولايات
المتحده بناء نظام عالمي جديد تقوده الصين
واشنطن تعتقد ان الحزام والطريق هو نقطه
انطلاق لبناء نظام جديد نظام عالمي جديد
يحل محل النظام الذي تقوده الولايات
المتحده منذ نهايه الحرب العالميه الثانيه
المشروع في جوهره بناء لكميه كبيره من
مشروعات البنيه التحتيه عبر دول اوراسيا
بشكل رئيسي اي قارتي اسيا واوروبا
والمستقر في ادبيات العلاقات الدوليه ان
من يتحكم في اوراسيا يحكم العالم هذه
واحده من كلاسيكيات العلاقات الدوليه لم
توجد توجد في التاريخ اي قوه عظمى لا
تسيطر على اسيا واوروبا او جزء كبير منهما
يعني وبعيدا عن النظريات تخيل لو نجحت
الصين في تحقيق هذا المشروع بشكل ناجح اي
انشات مشروعات طرق بريه وبحريه تربط الصين
ب 150 دوله حول العالم وبطول هذه الطرق
اقامت 50 منطقه اقتصاديه حره على الاقل
موانئ مطارات سكك حديديه فائقه السرعه
تنقل واردات الصين لهذه البلدان والعكس
وخطوط انابيب تنقل البترول والغاز من
مصادر انتاجه للصين ويتكامل المشروع مع
بنك الاستثمار الاسيوي وبنك التنميه
الجديده التي اقامته الصين مع دول بريكس
وطبيعي مع كل هذه المشروعات يزداد الطلب
على اليوان وتكثر الاساطير والقواعد
العسكريه الصينيه لحمايه كل هذه المصالح
هذا بدا ويحدث بالفعل لكن اذا اكتمل تمامه
فعلى امريكا وحلفائها السلام
وسواء كان الغرب صادقا في قراءه نوايا
الصين ام لا فان موقف الغرب وتشككه في
نوايا الصين زاد من التحديات التي تواجه
المشروع المشروع اجمالا بواجه تحديين
اساسيين تحدي الاول حرب امريكا وحلفائها
عليه وهذه الحرب تاخذ اربعه اشكال واحد
الشكل الاول يعني تشويه صوره المشروع
والضغط على الدول حتى لا تنضم اليه وهذا
لم ينجح كثيرا لان عدد من اقرب حلفاء
الولايات المتحده انضموا الى المشروع
حلفاء مثل من مثل اسرائيل مثل دول الخليج
مثل 18 دوله داخل الاتحاد الاوروبي اثنين
محاوله اضعاف الصين اقتصاديا بكل الوسائل
من خلال الحرب التجاريه وحرمان الصين من
التكنولوجيات الغربيه
الحساسه يعني او المتقدمه وده امر تحدثنا
عنه كثيرا وسوف نتحدث عنه اكثر ان شاء
الله في المستقبل
واحد نتائج مثلا هذه الحرب ان الصين لم
تعد في عام 2023
الشريك التجاري رقم واحد لامريكا لاول مره
منذ سنوات طويله ثلاثه محاولات امريكا
مؤخرا تقويه دور البنك الدولي وصندوق
النقد بحيث لا تحتاج الدول الناميه
والفقيره اللي بتهرب من الصندوق والبنك
وشروطهم الجائره بحيث لا يلجاوا الى الصين
اربعه واخيرا محاوله انشاء مشروعات بديله
للحزام والطريق لماذا تنضم الدول للحزام
والطريق لان الصين ببساطه بتوفر لهذه
الدول التمويل والتكنولوجيا اللازمه
لانشاء مشاريع بنيه تحتيه هامه جدا لدعم
اقتصادات هذه الدول تمام الغرب بيقول احنا
كمان نقدر نعمل كده وبالفعل اعلنوا في قمه
العشرين الاخيره التي عقدت يومين تسعه
وعشره سبتمبر الماضيين عن مشروع الممر الا
المشروع باختصار سلسله من مشروعات البنيه
التحتيه التي تربط الهند ودول الخليج
باوروبا عبر اسرائيل بشكل رئيسي مشروع
الممر باكمله نظريا هو جزء من مشروع اكبر
اسمه مشروع الشراكه من اجل البنيه التحتيه
العالميه والاستثمار او بي جي دبل اي
يمكنكم ان تبحثوا عنه هذا المشروع اعلنت
عنه رسميا مجموعه الدول السبعه في 2022
وقدرت انها سوف تخصص لاتمامه 600 مليار
دولار سوف تذهب كلها لانشاء مشاريع بنيه
تحتيه في الدول الفقيره والناميه وشركاء
الولايات المتحده وحلفائها لكن هذا
المشروع لم يدخل حيز التنفيذ حتى هذه
اللحظه لعده اسباب اهمها طبعا ان كثيرا من
دول الجي 7 او دول الدول السبع الصناعيه
غارقه في ازمات اقتصاديه
ازمه كورونا والحرب الروسيه الاوكرانيه
فما هو الحل يعني كيف يمكن ان نطلق
مشروعنا الكبير المنافس لمشروع الحزام
والطريق بينما نحن نعاني من ازمات الماليه
في الغرب الحل تمثل في ضم دول الخليج الى
هذا المشروع
الاستعانه بدول الخليج يحل كل المشكلات
ويحقق كل غايات واشنطن والدول الغربيه
المناوله للصين ليه اولا انضمام دول
الخليج وفر التمويل الذي تعجز عنه دول
الجي 7 مش قادره توفر تمويل كافي اثنين
يحقق هذا المشروع اهدافا سياسيه اخرى
لوشنطن اهمها دمج اسرائيل اكثر واكثر في
دول المنطقه ما يمهد مستقبلا لعقد اتفاقات
ابراهيميه اضافيه مع السعوديه مع الكويت
الى اخره ويضع طبعا المشروع في حال تمامه
ايران تحت ضغوط حتى تذعن للشروط الغربيه
او التصور الغربي لمستقبل هذه المنطقه
رابعا والاهم يخلق بديلا لمشروع الصين
اللي هو الحزام والطريق دول الخليج متحمسه
للحزام والطريق ولمشروع الممر الاقتصادي
واي مشروع اخر يحقق مصالحها لم تعد دول
الخليج راغبه في ان تكون محسوبه فقط على
المعسكر الامريكي وهي لن ترضى ان تكون
تابعه للصينيين والاشتراك في المشروعين
الحزام والطريق من ناحيه ومشروع الممر
الاقتصادي من ناحيه اخرى يمنحها هذه
الاستقلاليه وهذه الحريه
ويربطها بالاضافه الى كل ذلك بقوه
اقتصاديه صاعده مهمه وهي الهند ما يعني ان
دول الخليج على الورق مستفيد صافي اقول
على الورق لان المشروع كله ما زال على
الورق واخيرا دول الخليج
باشتراكها في مشروع الممر الاقتصادي
بتتحوط ايضا الاحتمال تعثر او تباطؤ مشروع
الحزام والطريق بدا ياخذنا للتحدث الثاني
الذي يواجه مشروع الصين انا تحدثت عن
التحدي الاول اللي بيتمثل في حرب الولايات
المتحده وحلفائه على المشروع واللي اخذت
اربع اشكال اشرت اليهم
التحدث الثاني هي الصعوبات الماليه اللي
ظهرت مؤخرا على مدى السنوات العشره
الماضيه مولت البنوك الصينيه بحماس شديد
عدد ضخم من مشروعات البنيه التحتيه بعد
هذه المشروعات فشل في تحقيق العوائد
المتوقعه وبعضها تعثر تماما الفشل ده ناتج
عن خلل في دراسه جدوى هذه المشاريع او
ناتج عن اسباب خارجه عن طبيعه المشروع
ودراسته وعن الصين كلها في الدول كثيره من
الدول اللي اشتركت مع الصين في مشروع
الحزام والطريق على وشك الافلاس لاسباب
الله علاقه لها بمشروع الحزام والطريق
وانما لاسباب خاصه بهذه الدول التي اقترضت
بدون حساب واللي تعرضت الى هزه
فيروس كورونا ثم الحرب الروسيه الاوكرانيه
لكن النتيجه واحده النتيجه ان الدول التي
اقترضت بشكل مكثف من الصين في اطار مشروع
الحزام والطريق غرقت في الديون والصين
ايضا باتت غارقه في الديون واحد اسباب غرق
الصين في الديون واصرافها في تمويل
مشروعات الحزام والطريق
اعطيكم مثل واحد من بين امثله كثيره للدول
شريكه في الحزام والطريق وغرقت مؤخرا في
الديون وهي زامبيا مجرد مثال امثله كثيره
جدا بس لما تشوفوا مثال زامبيا زامبيا
تحثرت في سداد سته وتلاته من عشره مليار
دولار ديون خارجيه منهم قد ايه نصيب الصين
اربعه وواحد من عشره مليار دولار الصين
نفسها ديونها بلغت في
202295 في المئه من الناتج المحلي
الاجمالي يعني لو الناتج المحلي الاجمالي
للصين مثلا 18 تريليون دولار هي مديونه
بثلاثه امثال هذا الرقم تقريبا
المسؤولين الصينيين مدركين لهذه المشاكل
والتحديات
ومدركين للصعوبات التي تواجه نموذج الحزام
والطريق وبداوا في محاولات لتلافي اخطائهم
السابقه يعني على مدار السنتين او الثلاثه
الاخيره قللوا القرود للدول الشريكه معهم
خفضوا معدل الفوائد على هذه القرود
ركزوا على دراسات الجدوى بشكل اكثر واكثر
وركزوا على ما اسموه مشاريع سمول بيوتيفول
صغيره ولكن جميله اي بشريه مدروسه بعنايه
ليس بالضروره ان تكون ضخمه مثل المشروعات
الاولى للمبادره ولكنها تقدم قيمه مضافه
للبلدان المقترضه من الصين وبالتالي عوائد
افضل
للصينيين الصين ايضا مدركه لابعاد الحرب
الغربيه عليها وعلى مشروعها وهي لهم
بالمرصاد ما يعني ان مشروع الحزام والطريق
بات مرهونا بمصير الصين كقوه عظمى الغرب
بيسعى لافشال المشروع ووقف صعود الصين
لصداره العالم والصين تستميت للحفاظ على
المشروع والابقاء على فرصها في الصداره
مفتوحه والوقت وحده سوف يحدد من ينتصر ومن
المهزوم اشكركم والى لقاء